et on commence par le procès en appel
pour l'extradition du lanceur d'alerté
julian assange deuxième jour aujourd'hui
de ce procès en deuxième les jours de
leçons de cet examen en appel par les
états unis ses soutiens vous ne voyez
restent mobilisés hier julian assange
n'a pas pu se rendre au tribunal pour
assister à cette audience il était trop
affaibli par son incarcération
physiquement on va faire le point tout
de suite à londres avec notre reporter
katia technique
[Musique]
bonjour katia vous êtes à londres et
vous suivez cet examen de l'appel des
etats-unis que s'est-il passé hier et
qu'attendre de cette deuxième journée
d'audience
alors bonjour aujourd'hui la défense va
tenter de contrer l'argumentaire hier
développé par james lewis le
représentant des américains à la cour il
lui s'est exprimé hier donc et il a
contesté dans tous ses détails le
rapport psychiatrique qui avait permis à
julien assange d'échapper à
l'extradition notamment le risque
suicidaire et pourtant c'est un expert
de renom incontesté jusqu'ici qui a
produit ce rapport par les américains
estime que le risque suicidaire a été
surévaluée et par exemple que la cour
n'a pas retenu le fait que les
américains disposaient de recours
d'attention pour éviter à un prévenu
d'attenter à sa vie et puis surtout ils
ont insisté sur toutes les garanties
qu'il pouvait offrir à julian assange
pour lui assurer de bonnes conditions de
détention par exemple que l'isolément ne
serait pas appliquée mais en réalité on
se rend compte que les américains
disposent de toutes les autorisations
nécessaires pour imposer toutes les
restrictions qu'ils souhaitent alors
tous ces arguments étaient déjà battu en
brèche hier par les avocats et les
proches de julian assange il y avait ici
hier assistant à l'audience le rédacteur
en chef de wikileaks le père de julian
assange également sa compagne stella
maurice en plus d'environ quelques
centaines de soutiens et en fait il ne
faut évidemment pas confiance aux
américains ils disent que julian assange
est victime de persécution politique
pour avoir dénoncé les crimes de guerre
américains vous le disais cette audience
hier avait un goût amer parce que julian
assange n'a pas assisté à cette audience
le matin un de ses avocats expliqué qu'
à cause d'une forte dose de médicaments
le fondateur de wikileaks avait demandé
à ne pas assister à cette audience et
c'était une requête qui avait été
acceptée par la cour or hier soir sa
petite amie a expliqué que ce n'était
pas le cas ce n'était pas à cause des
médicaments et qui n'avait pas assisté
donc pour le moment le mystère reste
entier on ne sait pas si julian assange
pourra se rendre à son audience
aujourd'hui en tout cas ce qu'on sait
c'est qu'une deuxième journée de
mobilisation se prépare ici
nous allons suivre et l'audience et la
mobilisation à londres devant le
tribunal si beaucoup qui tiens on va sur
eux cela évidemment dans nos prochaines
éditions avec vous merci katia pique
nique en direct de londres